moi
rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une émission spéciale pour en apprendre
un peu plus sur les sentiers labellisé
de la réunion en compagnie de bernard
labrosse chargé d'études écotourisme
alors nf
du volcan à bélouve de mafate à la
providence
il n'y a pas un coin de l'île dans
lequel on ne puisse randonnée plus de
900 kilomètres de sentiers sont
référencés au niveau départemental et
l'on peut sans doute doubler ce chiffre
si l'on ajoute les sentiers communaux
les sentiers privé et les sentiers
marron ses 960 km de sentiers référence
et constituer un réseau dense plus tôt
dans les eaux connecter à de nombreux
gîtes de montagne dont le gestionnaire
et l'office national des forêts la
moitié de ce réseau de sentiers
labellisée par la fédération de
randonnée pédestre
ce sont l'état ne gr et dr une
appellation nationale vieille de
plusieurs dizaines d'années que tous les
amateurs de randonnées connaissent sur
l'île il n'existe pas moins de 3 gr ou
sentier de grande randonnée le gr 1 qui
fait le tour du piton des neiges sur 60
km en passant dans l'es3 cyr le gr iii
qui fait le tour du cep de mac patte sur
47 km et surtout l'incontournable gère
de l'image forte de la rame dans l'est à
la réunion c'est la traversée la
traversée de l'île en douze jours le gr
2 c'est le premier qui a été imaginé et
c'est celui qui continue à avoir le plus
grand succès parce que ils représentent
ils une entité à lui-même
on traverse du nord au sud ou du sud au
nord en traversant les trois cirques en
passant sur les sommets les plus les
plus renommés les randonneurs extérieurs
viennent pour faire la traversée de
l'île de la réunion avec des clubs en
individuel il est connu dans tous les
milieux qui pratiquent la randonnée au
même titre que la traversée de la corse
que la traversée des alpes que la
traversée des pyrénées sa salle la même
valeur et la même promotion
à côté des 3 gr 2 100 autres kilomètres
de sentiers constituent le réseau des
pme sentiers de promenades et randonnées
c'est une sélection de 25 sentiers de
moins de 20 km tout autour de l'île que
l'on peut faire au maximum à la journée
parmi lesquels on retrouve des sentiers
forestiers hainard n'a choisi les
sentiers emblématique mais aussi des
sentiers beaucoup moins connue et dans
chaque microrégion on a ces deux
exemples je vais venir sur cilaos cilaos
on invite les gens à aller à la roche
merveilleuse et qui est un très grand
classique de sucre de cilaos
mais on les invite aussi à les voir la
chapelle la chapelle qui est beaucoup
moins connue et qui est un site
extrêmement intéressant et passionnant à
découvrir
la labellisation de ces 28 senti leur
garantit une bonne visibilité notamment
dans les topo-guides dont certains leur
sont intégralement dédié celui sur les
terres vient d'être par exemple réédité
en avril 2014
sur le terrain cela se traduit aussi par
un grand confort de pratiquer ces
sentiers sont le plus souvent faciles
d'accès très bien entretenue au même
titre que l'ensemble des sentiers
référence et léger air et terre
bénéficie en plus d'une signalétique
riche et importante en cours de
renouvellement depuis 2012
nous remettons à jour toute la
signalétique des sentiers à partir d'une
charte départementale
c'est une charte qui veut mettre en
valeur le territoire
d'abord par une signature une signature
qui la feuille de fin aux gens que l'on
retrouvera surtout les poteaux de ceux
de randonnée et ensuite une discrétion
une intégration paysagère mais aussi
faire vivre les sentiers tels que les gr
et lés p r on les retrouve sur la
signalétique
on retrouvera des numéros sur les
itinéraires des gr 2 à 3 et dpr deux
heures à vincennes ces numéros que l'on
a sur les guides que l'on achète en
librairie se retrouve sur le terrain
ap
parmi les informations importantes que
l'on retrouve sur les sentiers ou dans
les topo-guides figurent des estimations
sur les temps de marche
la randonnée est une activité accessible
au plus grand nombre du coureur aux
marmailles chacun peut découvrir la
montagne à son rythme il a donc fallu se
mettre d'accord sur une référence dans
notre norme c'est d'abord les temps de
marche sont affichés comme du temps réel
de marche on exclut tout arrêt et
ensuite nous nous basons à la montée sur
300 m de dénivelé 300 m de dénivelé à la
montée 400 m dénivelé à la descente en
terrain plat entre 3 et 4 km heure voilà
nos premières base d'estimations du
temps de marche que nous pondérons
ensuite pour tenir compte des dénivelés
impressionnants la réunion des pentes
très forte
et puis du climat
et
les sentiers labellisé g rpr sont donc
une formidable porte d'entrée vers la
montagne réunionnaise grâce aux
nombreuses informations disponibles pas
besoin d'être un randonneur aguerri pour
venir en découvrir les beautés
l'essentiel c'est de garder à l'esprit
qu'une sortie en montagne se prépare
toujours en amont sans oublier de se
renseigner sur l'état des sentiers
notamment après la saison cyclonique